Hi everyone.
Thank you so much for being here.
My name is Elise for coffer and I'm the global program manager for women at
Google.
I'm delighted to be here with mode today.
Moe gout.
Od is the chief business officer for x,
a serial entrepreneur and author of solve for happy mode.
Joined Google in 2007 to kickstart it's business in emerging markets.
In 2013 he moved to Google's infamous innovation arm,
Google x where he now leads the business strategy planning,
sales,
business development and partnerships.
Moas currently on a six month sabbatical to dedicate himself to his personal
moonshot mission of helping 10 million people find happiness.
So thank you so much Mo for being here.
I'd like to be here.
Thank you.
So what qualifies you as a businessman to write about happiness?
Hmm.
Okay,
that's a good start for the conversation.
Um,
I,
um,
I think what's happened is I've been a very successful businessman for a very
long time.
I,
uh,
I was one of the most,
as many of you know,
being the chief business officer of Google x is probably the,
you know,
the luckiest you can get in the professional world.
I've been that lucky almost,
uh,
since my very early,
you know,
uh,
start to in business and,
you know,
as,
as life,
uh,
was extremely kind to me,
you know,
an Egyptian who is educated in the public schools of Egypt.
I started to become very successful at a,
in my late twenties,
I was a director of a for the Middle East of a major consumer goods company.
I was a day trader making very,
very hefty returns at the time.
And I was miserable.
I was totally,
totally,
totally depressed.
Uh,
you know,
regardless of how much life gave me,
I continued to feel unhappy or,
you know,
I,
I had everything that we work so hard,
all our lives to achieve,
including a wonderful,
a wonderful family.
You know,
a wonderful wife,
uh,
two amazing children,
who,
you know,
filled our life with peace and happiness and fun.
And I constantly was depressed.
And being a Middle Eastern therapy was not really an option if you want.
Uh,
so I,
uh,
I did what I know how to do best at the time to dig myself out of my misery.
I sort of started to read,
uh,
extensively about the topic of happiness.
Uh,
I dedicated more than 10 years of my life to reading about the topic.
And that's a lot of hours.
If you think about it,
id that at least an hour or two a day,
uh,
on,
in the first couple of years,
I could not get it at all.
I couldn't understand what they were telling me.
There was a ton of amazing practice,
uh,
you know,
of things you can do to become happy.
Happiness isn't ancient science if you think about it,
but I just couldn't get it.
I,
you know,
it just did not speak to my mind at all.
And so I sort of used,
if you want my business background,
but more my engineering background to tackle the topic from a very,
very different point of view.
I started to look at the topic of happiness.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
from a mathematical scientific point of view,
assuming that,
you know,
being a young man who grew maybe in my mid twenties to be a very happy young
man,
and then we ran out of happiness.
That must have meant that something went wrong with the machine,
that,
you know,
this was operating fine and then it wasn't working anymore.
So maybe we should unassembled the machine and find a way to find out which
parts are not working and then make them work again.
Or maybe the machine was just not suited for the current environment.
Maybe,
you know,
if you take a sports car,
and I'm not a sports car in any way,
but to,
you know,
if you take a sports car and put it out in the middle of the desert,
uh,
it gets stuck.
It gets unhappy.
And so this approach to happiness,
that engineering,
scientific,
uh,
experimental approach to happiness,
reflected a very,
very,
very different back,
you know,
very different perspective,
very different,
uh,
you know,
approach to solving the problem.
And,
and that's what I summarize in software.
Happy.
Hm.
So after all this research,
you a,
you found happiness in many ways,
but then something,
something happened.
What,
what ended up making you write this book?
So,
so I,
um,
search,
as I said,
took around 10 years or so,
and I,
and I was at the point in my life where almost nothing could dent my hat,
my happiness,
you know.
Uh,
again,
I,
I'm,
I come from a Middle Eastern background,
so,
you know,
post nine 11,
I would travel to the u s for business at least once a month.
You know,
it would take me 12 to 14 hours to get to the u s and then I would almost
always,
you know,
spent two to three hours in random check in,
in a homeland security,
right.
With this silly smile on my face,
nothing would make me unhappy.
I would win a deal,
lose a deal,
gets stuck in traffic.
It doesn't really matter.
I was just constantly a okay,
was life grateful and,
and,
you know,
enjoying every bit of it.
Uh,
um,
and,
and in an interesting way,
I think this must have been my training if you want,
because,
um,
in,
in 2014,
I think I got the ultimate test of,
of being able to stay peaceful and calm that a parent could ever do.
My,
my wonderful [inaudible] who was 21 at the time,
21 and a half at the time.
Beautiful,
handsome.
Why is kind and honest young man who,
uh,
made me proud in every possible way.
Who was my friend,
uh,
much more than my son.
You know,
I,
I that I,
you know,
I had him at the,
at a very young age and so we played video games together.
We played music together,
we read books together.
We,
you know,
he was,
he was a very funny young man.
And so we watched a ton of comedy.
It was always an amazing experience to be with Allie.
Uh,
he came to visit us in Dubai in July,
2014 and instead of,
uh,
of going through a wonderful vacation idea,
unfortunately he was diagnosed with an appendix,
inflammation.
Uh,
we took him to a local hospital and the surgeon made five mistakes in a row,
uh,
in,
in four hours.
Our life turns from planning to for the best,
you know,
time of our life,
uh,
to losing the one that meant most to us.
And,
um,
and even though the pain was unbearable,
I think anyone here who has children will know that,
um,
to,
to lose a child is almost to lose a part of your heart.
Truly.
I,
I'm,
I'm even lost for words today.
Two and a half years later,
I,
I honestly cannot describe what it feels exactly there is that lasting pain if
you want.
But we were so peaceful and calm as a family.
I wouldn't say we were happy.
We were,
uh,
you know,
that would be a big exaggeration,
but we were not unhappy.
We,
we were not angry at the world.
We were not disgruntled with what happened.
We did not want to kill the,
the,
the surgeon or we didn't want to,
you know,
blame ourselves for the rest of our life,
for,
for driving him to that specific hospital.
And,
uh,
in an interesting way,
when people came to Ellis Memorial,
they would come in crying and hundreds,
probably more than a thousand people came and they would come in crying and they
would then we would hug them and we would explain to them our view of,
of,
of life and the life and death.
And we would explain to them our view of happiness and,
and how we go through life.
And they would smile.
And then,
you know,
if you,
if you did not know the background to the event,
you would have thought that this is maybe Ellie's birthday or something.
Everyone was smiling and hugging and laughing,
remembering wonderful memories of valley.
And you know,
the atmosphere was amazing.
And so my friends basically started to say,
you have to write this down.
And An id had actually asked me before he left it.
It's almost as if he knew he was going to leave.
He sort of dictated his will a few days before and told me you need to continue
to do,
to make a difference to the world.
But maybe you should start to depend on your heart a little more,
you know,
sort of on top of all of the business and finance and technology that you've
been doing all your life,
there is another part of you that you may want to share with the world.
And so I sat down to write 17 days exactly 17 days after id left and I could not
stop.
And you know,
I suppose local Helio says when,
when you know your life's purpose,
the universe conspires to make it happen.
Everything fell in place for four and half months later I had 600 pages of
manuscript.
I met one of the best agents in the business,
Michael Carlisle from inquiry,
who introduced me to publishers across the world.
Uh,
today we are published in more than 12 languages even before the launch of the
book.
And,
uh,
including some of the top publishers worldwide,
Simon Schuster a Norstar way,
and Andy Mcmillan's bluebird.
So,
uh,
it's definitely been a,
a mission in the making if you want.
That's such a beautiful way to honor your son.
And that was such a powerful ask of him to do the work of your heart.
How is it feeling to do that work of your heart?
Um,
it,
um,
I th I think what's,
what you realize after a while is that when you lose a loved one,
and definitely when you lose a child,
the pain remains okay.
It doesn't go away.
Uh,
you know,
you,
most,
most of us who have experienced the loss of someone they love would think that
they were given one choice.
Right.
And the choice would be to sort of surrender to the harshness of life and,
and,
uh,
and you know,
just accept and cry and close your door and decay.
Right.
Uh,
I think very early on I realized that I was really given two choices.
One was to close my door and decay and it wouldn't bring it back.
And,
and the other was to do this,
uh,
try and honor Riley in a,
in a,
in a way that sort of tells the world about his way of living.
Right?
I mean,
it was so peaceful and going through life,
he actually had the tattoo on his back that,
that thread,
the gravity of the battery means nothing to those sps.
And unsurprisingly,
when he was going into the operations room,
the last thing he did is he set up and then through his scrubs,
I saw that tattoo.
That was the very last thing he told me.
If you want now we all go through harsh events in our life.
And imagine if you,
uh,
if you can share a way of living with 10 million people who will go through the,
the harshness of life and instead of closing their doors and decaying or closing
their doors and feeling unhappy or disgruntled with life,
you know,
imagine if I can honor it by having 10 million people remember his way and
hopefully send him a happy wish.
Uh,
I've,
I've spoken to around 12,000 people so far,
uh,
about the concepts of the book.
And every time I speak about it publicly,
I get hundreds of people who will tell me this,
change our life.
You know,
I've,
I've spent a privileged life working on projects like project Lu and,
or you know,
on Google itself in emerging markets to spread the,
the,
the amazing knowledge that comes with Google to every language and market in the
world.
And I will tell you,
I have rarely ever found anything more rewarding than to,
than to show people,
sort of the defects that our brains take us through and make us miserable
sometimes for a lifetime.
And once you see through them,
they go away.
Right.
It's nothing is more rewarding.
Yeah.
So we've done a few courses here at Google and I've taken hundreds of people
through with the content and a lot of them,
y'all saying it's life changing.
How would you summarize in just a few minutes what your happiness model is?
How is this different from other books about happiness?
Yeah,
I think,
I think the,
the biggest,
uh,
I mean Googlers and most,
most of us,
what I call Modern Day warriors today,
people,
people who get stuck on the one on one and you know,
and fight in meetings and have to close deals,
right.
You,
you know,
we don't have the time for eat,
pray,
love,
or to go and live in an ashram somewhere.
I think most of us need to understand how something works before we are told
what to do with it to make it work better.
And so,
um,
you know,
my,
my approach started with some very basics by the way.
I mean,
uh,
and,
and we do that.
I [inaudible] recording the trainings is when you ask people what is happiness?
Most people don't even know what,
you know,
what is the,
the,
the thing they've been searching for.
And so,
you know,
we take a very simple engineering approach to this.
We say,
okay,
let's plot as many,
you know,
a arbitrary data points as you can recall about moments when you felt happy and
find the trend line between them.
The equation that describes this trend line is really what happiness is,
right?
So,
you know,
and,
and there could be a million ways you can describe happiness.
The one that is common across all human beings,
across all moments of happiness,
at least.
The one I found was this,
that your happiness is equal to or greater than the difference between your
perception of the events of your life and your expectations from how of how life
should behave.
Right.
So in a very interesting way,
every single moment in your life with your,
what you felt happy,
it was a moment where you felt that life was going your way.
Okay.
Regardless of how realistic your expectation from life,
as if life throws you something,
it's like,
hey,
you know what,
uh,
I,
um,
I should lose 25 pounds in the next two and a half weeks.
You know what,
I have this very important event in Rio de Janeiro and I really need to lose
that.
Right?
If you don't,
you get upset.
It's like,
seriously,
who loses 25 pounds in two and a half weeks?
Right?
And,
and you start to go like,
all my metabolism is wrong.
And you know,
I was created in a way where I,
you know,
I,
I really don't eat at all,
but look at me,
I don't know.
You know,
we,
we start to describe things to ourself that are so unrealistic just because life
did not meet what we expect.
Okay?
Now with that equation in mind,
you start to realize that most of,
uh,
of our hat on happiness truly is a,
in our head.
Okay?
We think of the events of life in a certain way.
We compare that to our expectations of how life should behave.
And when,
when the event,
mrs the expectation,
the thought is,
triggers,
unhappiness,
you do nothing about it most of the times.
So your brain goes like,
but I told you something was wrong.
It brings it up again and it triggers unhappiness.
And then,
you know,
you,
you go through that too,
what I call the suffering cycle.
You know,
an event triggers a thought,
but then the thought triggers suffering and the suffering,
you know,
is followed by inaction.
So it triggers more thought,
more suffering,
more in action and so on.
And life continues that way for some of us for years,
for years.
Right?
Um,
so the interesting thing is there is a way to shortcut that cycle.
So,
so I work or you know,
I offer a model that I call six,
seven,
five,
six,
seven.
Five is basically the six and the seven are the reasons why we more often than
not end up thinking that the events of our life don't meet our expectations even
though most of the time life is okay,
right?
Uh,
the six is six grand illusions for us to succeed and be successful Google
employees,
what we do is we learn certain skills that allow us to navigate the modern
world,
uh,
that make us successful.
But to do that we have to start dealing with things not exactly as they really
are.
I mean,
let me give you an example.
We all are very proficient to,
you know,
in terms of handling time,
we all,
we all know how to be punctual.
We all,
we all know how to start a meeting on time,
how to end the meeting on time,
how to plan for tomorrow's meeting.
But time is nothing like what we think it is.
As,
as a matter of fact,
I use very,
very,
uh,
complex science presented in a very simple way.
In the chapter about time or I basically show you from the theory of relativity
that the only slice of time you will ever experience is the slice of now.
The only time you will ever live is now.
You have never lived in the past.
You will never live in the future.
But because we are so adept at thinking about the future too,
to plan for it and thinking about the past,
to learn from it,
we end up in those cycles of thoughts that completely destroy our happiness.
They make us efficient,
but who wants to solve for efficiency?
If you're eventually going to end up unhappy?
So six grand illusions put us in a state of sadness.
They put us in a state of confusion,
right?
It's like constant,
uninterrupted suffering.
If you go above those,
you end up in a place where you are allowed to think about every event of your
life.
Take every event of your life through the happiness equation.
You take an event,
you compare it to our expectations.
If it's,
if the,
if you end up with a positive thought,
yeah,
this is better than my expectations,
you're happy.
Okay.
If you end up with a negative sort of thoughts that no,
this misses my expectations,
you're unhappy.
And that incessant thought cycle,
you know,
is,
this is a thought is a cycle that unfortunately humans on average,
this is scientifically research in the University of Texas,
will end up thinking a negative thought 60 to 70% of the time.
Not because the world is bad and missing out expectations 60 or 70% of the time,
but because there are seven a blind spots in the way we look at life,
we look at life in a way that was designed for the caveman years.
So those blind spots makers,
let's say they make our brain grumpy,
they sort of make our brain constantly come back to us with the results of the
happiness equation that should make us unhappy,
right?
They make us safe and sort of,
you know,
they help with our survival,
but they make us unhappy.
And so if you manage to fix the seven blind spots,
if you manage to see through them,
it's suddenly you'll find yourself.
When you compare events to expectations in your happiness equation,
you're constantly going up to the happiness quadrant.
The five in my model,
however,
is if you continue to do this long enough,
if you continue to compare events to expectations without the six grand
illusions,
without the seven blind spots,
very frequently you will realize that most events of life should meet your
expectations,
okay?
Even the harsh ones,
by the way,
if you know the truth about life,
you should expect them.
You know,
we all know that change is the only constant,
right?
That we should expect change tomorrow,
We should expect that tomorrow is not going to be like today.
Now,
if you,
if you allow yourself to,
uh,
to look at the world this way,
then when change happens,
it doesn't miss your expectations anymore.
You constantly feel okay with it.
You feel happy about it.
And so I say,
if you hang onto those five ultimate truth,
you won't even need to solve the equation anymore.
More frequently than not,
you will just be okay.
You will be happy in a state that I call the state of joy,
uninterrupted happiness.
All the time.
Okay.
So that's complex stuff that I want to unpack a few things in particular.
So you brought up time,
which was one of the grand illusions and the importance of the present moment.
Why is it so important and how does it relate to our happiness?
It is complex stuff by the way.
So,
so one,
one of the differences between salt for happy,
any other happiness books is,
you know,
it,
it is truly a book for reflection.
So,
so you read,
you,
you think about it,
you go like,
what did he just say?
I didn't believe that all my life.
And then you read it again.
Okay.
And I,
I don't know if I,
if you know,
if you recall,
we spoke about the concept of early readers.
So I wrote this book like a Googler would,
you know how we use the,
uh,
Google docs too,
to review proposals or clients,
you know,
presentations or whatever together.
So I did that actually when I,
when I got to version two of the book,
I posted it online.
I put a,
you know,
a message on social media and got 500 early,
there's people that are,
don't even know,
uh,
who basically went into the book and edited it themselves.
They would go like,
no,
I don't like the sentence.
Maybe you should make it this way.
Or you know,
he is a bit of research that proves what you're talking about or a bit of
research that this proves what you're talking about.
And they would argue between them and you know,
which was an incredible experience.
So,
so I got tens of thousands of comments that made version three of the book
really what almost written by the readers if you want.
Now you know,
when,
when you think about,
uh,
about the,
the,
the pressure that we go through,
going back to the topic of time,
the pressure that we go through with time is,
um,
you know,
there are various views of time.
Okay.
Uh,
time.
here in the West we are,
you know,
we are clog based,
we are a clock based culture.
We respond to the clock,
the clock ticks and we follow.
Right.
And it's surprising when I speak to someone who is so punctual and so into that
culture,
for them to know that there are other cultures around the world that are not
like that at all,
right?
The majority of the world,
as a matter of fact,
Latin American,
southern Europe,
Middle East,
Africa,
some know Indian subcontinent and so on,
our events based,
they would prioritize the value of the event higher than the value of time.
So if we're having a good conversation and someone says,
ops times up,
right in Latin America,
or they will say,
hey,
that's okay,
we can take 10 more minutes on this.
It's,
it's worse.
Why that's not the case here.
And so that kind of knowledge of what time is,
allows you to think about it slightly differently.
But the deeper knowledge really is when you start to realize how time itself,
from a physics point of view,
what it is,
right?
No one really knows what time is.
As a matter of fact,
uh,
we know how to measure it and what,
what we measured,
we don't really measure time.
What we measure is we measure mechanical movements.
If you want that are sort of associated with times,
you know,
whether that's,
the rising of the sun or the more,
you know,
the,
the change of the seasons or you know,
the very,
very highly accurate,
uh,
you know,
um,
atomic clocks,
you know,
which measured the oscillations of certain items.
Um,
but what we're measuring truly is something that is unknown.
Okay.
As a matter of fact,
if you understand,
if you understand Einstein's view of relativity,
we,
you know,
what we live in is not a three dimensional space.
We live in a four dimensional space,
one of which is the Arrow of time.
The only,
the only difference between our ability ability to move in space and our ability
to move in time is that we're governed by the Arrow of time,
which basically means that the entire universe with you,
and it is propelled from second to second across the Arrow of time where,
you know,
he imagines it as a loaf of bread where you cut through the loaf of space time
and every instance is the entire universe at a specific instance in time.
It goes a lot more bizarre when you understand the time is so relative that it
changes for you and for me.
Not only that,
you know,
if what I'm talking about is boring for you,
you feel that the time is moving slower,
but truly,
if you're a,
you know,
an on top of Bosh Khalifa,
the highest tower in the world time,
we'll tick slower,
uh,
for you.
Uh,
sorry,
we'll take faster for you than if you were at the bottom of,
of,
of butch.
Halifa.
If you're moving fast,
time will move differently.
And so time truly is an illusion.
The only truth about time is this second,
I mean this second,
no,
this second,
right?
That's how it is.
Okay.
Yet most of us,
especially the professional thinkers we live in the second that will happen in
two and a half hours from now.
And we think about that and we,
you know,
then we shift back to the second that happened two and a half hours ago when you
were,
you know,
coming to work in a taxi and someone was rude to you,
right?
We are either in regret or in worry all the time.
While the truth is,
this is all you will ever experience.
Now what I do is in,
in solve for happy is I don't tell you that mindfulness works for you,
okay?
Because mindfulness does work.
Presence does work.
Awareness does work.
This is science.
That's as ancient as humanity itself,
but now you know why.
Now you understand.
Why is it that living in any other moments other than the present moment truly
is just living inside your head.
Because those moments will never exist until you lived them and have never
existed until you were in them.
And moment in the past truly was a moment of now.
Yeah.
Now as we go through this with,
you know,
Modern Day warriors as,
as I say,
people who are engaged in the real world,
suddenly you understand why presence is important,
but you don't need to do it in the meditation room anymore,
okay?
You can do it everywhere.
You can pay attention to a presentation,
you can pay attention to,
you know,
the trees that are around you are around you and you're stuck in traffic instead
of just living inside your head,
cursing the day you lived in that city.
Okay.
So speaking of living in fighter had one of the trickiest delusions is the
illusion of thought.
Yeah.
What do you mean by that?
I think the fundamental,
uh,
um,
premise I'm,
I build,
sought for happy on is that
emotions are the results of your thoughts,
right?
And every thought that you have in inside your head is a thought that you would
associate a lot more with if you thought that,
if you believed that the person thinking inside your head is you right?
Of course,
you know,
spirituality will tell you the person inside your head is not you.
Okay.
There are so many terminologies for it.
Uh,
you know,
I,
some religious beliefs will believe that it's,
you know,
at the devil and an angel who have their conference room inside your head.
You know,
they have chatting all the time.
One of them is telling you to go right.
And the other is telling you to go wrong.
Right?
Uh,
you know,
others will say our quarterly for example,
which definitely is one of my teachers cause it the thinker.
Uh,
you know,
there are lots of ways to associate with sought as if thought is not you.
Okay.
Even though the modern Western belief is I think therefore I am now in software
happy.
I basically provide very concrete scientific evidence.
That's the thoughts in your head are just a biological function.
Just like you know,
you breathe,
your lungs are tasked with the uh,
you know,
uh,
important survival task of taking oxygen into your blood and taking co two out
of your blood.
Uh,
you know,
your,
your brain is,
you know,
it's tasked with the idea of providing you a,
and you know,
comprehension of the real world in the only building blocks.
You know,
how to understand after you've learned words,
words,
right?
So once,
once we start to comprehend the word word,
word around us in the form of words,
you need to start company.
You know,
continuing to look at the world this way,
you cannot observe the world silently and make a decision.
Unfortunate,
unfortunately your brain is constantly translating that into language,
right?
And so that voice inside your head,
you know,
books like thinking fast and slow,
we'll tell you a lot about how that voice,
the conversation,
the almost the conflict inside your head is,
you know,
basically different sides of your brain trying to make sense of the word right.
Uh,
once you start to realize that,
um,
that sought is not you thought is just a biological function.
And I,
I,
I'm sorry to use bad English here,
but you know,
I always take the example of saying your colon is uh,
is responsible for creating crap and you know,
your head is sometimes responsible for creating more crap.
And,
and if you,
if you start to see it that way or you suddenly tried to tell you if it started,
suddenly realize that you,
one,
you don't always have to obey by the way,
because your brain's function as a biological function here is to present you
with as many ideas as possible,
right?
It's up to you to choose.
Right?
And tool is you don't have to associate.
So if you,
if you get a a thought that that's a little,
uh,
you know,
crazy,
that doesn't mean you're crazy.
I'm telling you actually put that thought into action.
It's just a thought presented to you can tell your brain,
hey,
thanks brain.
Thank you very much.
I realize by the way,
that you're not me.
I realize you're doing your biological function very well.
Uh,
thanks for presenting this idea.
Can you bring me a better idea?
Right.
And I know I'm,
I make that sound easy.
And of course there are tons of techniques that I discuss around how you can
make that a common practice.
But it's so interesting when you start to see the world from the perspective of
it's not,
I think therefore I am.
It's I am.
Therefore,
I think it's almost an,
it's,
I am,
therefore my brain thinks right?
If you make that separation,
your,
your view of the world will never be the same again.
Okay.
And so this relates a little bit to control and you are admitted,
Lee,
a retired control freak.
What have you learned about control and the illusion of control?
Yeah,
I apologize for everyone that I tried to control in my life before.
Um,
I mean don't laugh.
I'm,
I know you're doing it yourself.
So,
uh,
we try to control everything in our life,
right?
We believe that,
uh,
you know,
it's almost our function again,
by the way,
this is the expanded,
uh,
um,
functionality of your brain.
The reason why our species survived is not only did we manage to coordinate the
events of the world and run from the tiger when the tiger showed up,
but we actually managed to plan ahead and say,
hey,
if we go down that path or do we go into that cave that will be a tiger there.
It's not very wise to do this.
We,
there are no more tigers in our cities,
but we continue to plan and control obsessively.
Right?
Uh,
and,
and the funny bit is that we actually somehow managed to convince ourselves that
we have control.
And you know,
one of the exercises I do in the training as Google is I basically allow you to
measure how often things go out of control.
And I get an answer between the,
that falls somewhere between very frequently and all the time,
right?
Uh,
all right.
And,
and of course you can tell yourself,
but I bring it back in control and then you start to think and ask yourself and
how much effort exactly did you put into this?
Was it really worth it to control,
you know,
the uh,
um,
arrive the temperature of the coffee.
I told you that example about,
you know,
can we control the coffee machine so that it fills in a huff announced small so
that it's closer to the top,
to the top so that we have more efficiency for our employees so that they are a
little more awake through one cup of coffee.
Right.
It's crazy really,
when you start to think about all of the things we try to control.
Now,
Nassim Taleb in his incredible book,
the Black Swan,
uh,
talks about those massive events that are so they're in their occurrence that
when,
when they occurred,
they would be compared to spotting a black swan instead of all of the white
swans we know,
but that when they occur,
they so drastically change the world,
you know,
Google being one of them by the way,
so,
so no one expected Google to happen.
And when Google happened,
it completely democratized our approach to inflammation.
World War One is a,
is another one that he,
that he cites,
um,
and,
and every one of us,
not only at the macro level of our economies and politics and what have you,
but even though,
you know,
in our normal personal lives,
we have black swans,
you know,
my,
my black swan was take was losing.
Golly,
okay.
Um,
and,
and on top of that,
we,
you know,
and those dual drastically change your life.
But the ones that you don't notice are even more potent if you want,
you know,
uh,
they call them butterfly effects and butterfly effect,
I'm sure you all know is,
are those,
you know,
uh,
when,
when you're doing weather forecasts,
they say that,
um,
wind speed changes that are so small that they could be comparable to a
butterfly flapping its wings in Brazil,
could cause a hurricane or a sunny day in Florida,
right?
And Butterfly Effects Happen every single second of your life.
So many of them,
as a matter of fact,
right?
You,
you came here today,
you sat on a yellow chair,
not a red chair or you came here.
I don't know.
I don't want to disappoint the ones that came a little late,
but you came a little early.
Uh,
you got to,
you know,
your copy of the book,
right?
You came a little late,
you didn't get your copy of the Vulcan.
So,
you know,
not,
it's not only about saving the price of the book,
but maybe you read the book today and it will affect you tomorrow and so on and
so forth.
Right?
Uh,
and so,
you know,
butterfly effects are endless.
My Butterfly effects are,
you know,
whatever it is that Allie has eaten maybe two weeks earlier,
uh,
you know,
that caused his him appendix to be inflamed or you know,
the proximity of our home to that specific hospital.
Maybe if we had chosen a different home,
we would have gone to a different hospital and this was a choice we made years
earlier.
Now,
between the two of those,
you realize that you have zero control.
Nothing.
There is nothing that you have control over,
but has other than two things,
and I discussed those heavily in the book,
I discuss that the only things you can have control over are your actions,
not the results of your actions and your attitude,
right?
Your attitude truly is the game changer.
You know,
if you,
if you wake up in the morning and expect today to be a horrible day because
maybe it's raining or whatever,
you know what,
it's going to end up being a horrible day.
And at the end of the day,
you're going to tell yourself,
oh,
I told you it was going to be horrible.
You know,
I'm the article.
I know everything.
You know,
just because a train,
no,
it ended up being horrible because you wanted it to be a horrible,
you spotted everything that was horrible and you acted horrible,
right?
And then you're going to blame the rain.
Now,
there is a lot of costs for unhappiness when we,
uh,
when we try to control further than our actions and our attitude,
you know,
some of the most profound spiritual beliefs,
in Hinduism,
for example,
the concept of detachment,
uh,
of,
you know,
I'm going to do the absolute best I can and whatever the result is not entirely
up to me.
It's up to me and a few black swans and a million butterflies.
And by the way,
7.2 other,
uh,
billion human beings who also have their own view of world and maybe trillions
of other Bx,
right?
All of that comes together to create what might be your reality and it will
always be outside your control.
So the last thing that I want to,
um,
ask before I open it up for audience questions is about the concept of good
versus bad and our desires.
Humans to constantly label things as good for a spot.
You lost your son.
I've lost my brother at immediately felt like,
oh,
this is such a bad,
bad thing.
Um,
can you talk a little bit about your,
your take on that and committed acceptance?
Yeah.
Um,
so,
so the,
the,
the illusion that drives us to believe that something is good in some things
bad.
You know,
the fundamental illusion is what I call the illusion of knowledge.
And I think you Google is no that much,
much better than I do.
I actually,
uh,
I sort of understood the illusion of knowledge when I came to Google because I
came to Google from Microsoft.
I was a senior executive who worked in technology for years.
I thought I knew it all right.
I thought I had nothing more to learn.
And I came here in this place,
completely opened my eyes and you know how it is,
right?
You know,
and I joined in 2007 and I would be in a meeting room and the youngest person in
the room who may have started two weeks ago,
we'll say,
Mo,
I think you're an idiot.
And I'm like,
okay,
um,
can you tell me a little bit more about that?
You know,
like why?
And he would give me data and information that actually changes my point of
view.
And often a couple,
a few weeks later,
we would realize that he too was wrong and that we missed something else.
Right.
And if you actually look at our entire scientific history,
there is that cycle I call it,
which is basically discovery,
debate,
acceptance and arrogance.
Every everything we go through in,
in our science,
you know,
background is,
we discover something.
Everyone argues it and says,
oh,
you're absolutely crazy.
The earth is flat.
You,
you know,
this whole earth is round thing.
You're crazy,
right?
And then there is enough evidence provided.
And then we go like,
okay,
let's accept that the earth is round,
but it's the center of the heavenly universe.
Right?
And then we are arrogant about that new knowledge and then someone else comes
and says,
Hey,
by the way,
we might be the one revolving around the sun.
As a matter of fact,
it seems that this is what it is,
a new discovery.
And so we debate,
right.
And that cycle continues.
Right?
We don't really know.
And when it,
when it comes to knowledge,
I think the most
eye opening part of knowledge for me it was that whole concept of labeling
something good and labeling another thing bad.
Okay.
I'm not saying right and wrong by the way.
Mortality is different,
but good and bad is,
you know,
I wish this did not happen because it's,
contradicts my expectations from life.
This is bad.
Okay.
And how often do you recall parts of your own life when something that appeared
the bad,
when it happened,
it turned out to be the best thing that ever happened to you.
As a matter of fact,
quite often,
most of the profound,
you know,
fundamental changes that really made you who you are start to lose something
that you labeled as bad.
Okay.
And,
and somehow when we label it as bad first we curse life for a few years and then
we go like,
wow,
that was nice.
Um,
I'm okay with that now.
Right?
And of course I refer to a,
an interesting test.
I call the eraser test and I ask the readers to go back and,
and really,
really dig through the events of their life and see which of them would they
really erase.
I mean,
of course there may be one or two that you may still erase that you really,
that were so bad to you for,
for your life.
But most of the events that were bad that you considered bad at at that point in
the past become good overtime and you would not erase them.
You would actually look back at them and say,
these were the most important things that happened to me.
More importantly,
of course.
And in an interesting way,
a bit contradictory to the western individualistic view of the world.
Uh,
you know,
the,
the idea of what's good for me is bad for you and what's bad for you is good for
me or what's bad for me?
It's good for you.
Right?
So,
so,
so the whole idea of if we really look at the world much more or the universe
much more as oneness as we're into the,
we're in this together,
okay.
That if we all succeed,
we succeed together,
then there is really nothing that's good or bad.
I mean,
I cite the example of how Allie was,
um,
uh,
you know,
idea when he went to the hospital,
he,
eh,
he was fasting for the month of Ramadan.
And so the doctors basically said,
hey,
he might as well continue fasting until,
uh,
the operation because you know,
of the anesthesia and all of that.
And so by the time it left our worlds,
he was thirsty for almost 24 hours.
And,
you know,
on top of all of the pain I was going through,
that completely pained me.
It completely hurt me that my son had to suffer for 24 hours before,
uh,
before he,
he,
he had to leave us.
And,
and so,
you know what,
what I did sitting outside the ICU is I made a promise that,
you know,
I'm going to try and do something for the people that actually suffer this every
single day.
There are,
there are more than 780 million people around the world who do not have access
to clean water at all,
right?
So they suffer what I suffered once in his life everyday of their life.
And so,
so,
so basically when you think about it,
what happened to Allie was bad for Allie.
Horrible for me.
Okay?
But it might have been good for a few thousand people or tens of thousands of
people that got some blessing of getting some clean water as a result of that
event.
So can you mark it good or bad?
As a matter of fact,
if I went back to Ireland now and I said,
Allie,
would you fast 24 hours for tens of thousands of people to get water?
Would say absolutely.
That would be a good thing to do,
right?
So our perception of good and bad constantly puts us in a coordinator where we
are so unhappy with life.
So let me just say a bit of a six year old year old attitude,
right?
It's like,
do your homework or eat your vegetables.
Now it's bad.
I don't like my vegetables.
Right?
Come on man.
Seriously,
you're going to need them when you're my age.
So you know,
just go for it and life will go on.
Right?
And so sometimes I wish we look at life a little more holistically and,
and realize that nothing truly is good or bad.
I mean,
check Shakespeare says that nothing's good or bad,
but thinking is what makes it so,
yeah.
Okay.
Last question is how you came up with this target.
You talk a lot about thinking 10 x and you know,
setting targets being really important.
What is your target?
What does success look like?
My,
my uh,
yeah,
I'm,
I mean,
I'm supposed to be talking about happiness,
but I still do that as a businessman.
Like I set my cell phone an Okr,
right?
So my,
my,
you know,
I have to say,
I don't know if I came up with the target toward the target came up with me to
be honest.
But,
uh,
there was a point in a,
you know,
as I started to discuss,
especially during the process of the early readers,
uh,
you know,
review of the book where I started to realize that the message was actually
working.
Uh,
and you know,
in,
in conversations with my publishers,
they were talking about,
you know,
the reach of books and so on and so forth.
And I said,
well,
maybe I should set myself a target so that we at least can measure and move
forward.
And I gave myself a target of trying,
you know,
I call it 10 million,
10 million happy.
So I,
I'm trying to reach 10 million people with this message of happiness.
Hopefully to get 10 million people to Click on the counter on my website and
say,
yes,
you made me happy right.
Now,
of course,
you can imagine as a,
as a businessman,
that's cheating because if I actually do get 10 million people and they do go
out and tell two of two friends,
then hopefully through six degrees of separation,
we can get to hundreds of millions or maybe a billion.
I don't know.
Right.
But,
but,
but to me,
I felt that,
you know,
what would be a better way to honor Ali?
I mean,
and I,
and I'd say selfishly,
I don't think it brings him back.
I don't think it's,
it takes away the pain,
but at least it somehow makes it feel a little better.
Okay.
I,
I'm sure,
I'm sure at least that it somehow would make him proud of me and,
and I think that definitely has been driving my life for the last two and a half
years.
I think that to be true.
Yup.
All right.
Let's go ahead and open it up for audience questions.
Uh,
so you,
you were talking about how the brain produces a lot of different thoughts,
you know,
that are related to what,
what we're perceiving.
And I'm curious if you,
uh,
believe in freewill and how that sort of affects your whole outlook on life.
And then the second question is,
it is,
is if you think freewill even matters,
you know,
to what you're,
uh,
you're trying to talk to venture to happiness.
Okay.
So first let's talk about salt and then talk to talk about three ways.
So,
so there are two,
there are three types of thoughts right there is that,
that chatter,
that incessant thought that happens,
someone somewhere in the midline,
areas of our brains.
This is googleable by Mri where it's the constant useless thinking.
It's like,
you know,
the taxi driver was rude to me.
Oh my God,
he was rude to me.
Life shouldn't be this way.
You know,
I should kill myself on why can I live in America anymore?
If the taxi drivers are rude and so on and so forth,
and you don't,
you don't,
you never turn that into action.
You just turn your life into misery because of it.
And,
and as I,
you know,
as I say,
some of us would take days off thinking about an event like that.
Uh,
but this is usually start the useful thought happens on the right hand side in
the insula.
So there are two types of,
of,
of useful thoughts.
One is the uh,
insightful thinking where you solve a problem.
Okay.
So you know,
you,
you can worry about an exam,
uh,
that you are,
or a presentation that you have tomorrow and it would happen in the incessant
thought space,
but you can move it to the,
uh,
you know,
to the,
to the right hand side of your brain and turn that into,
let's put the presentation together.
Let's work on what the messages are going to be.
You're actually practically working through that.
And it happens in two areas of the right hand side of your brain.
Or you can actually focus on the experience of preparing a presentation.
Look at the colors of it,
reviewing it and so on.
Also happens in the right hand side of the brain and in your insula.
So,
so those,
those are useful thoughts,
thoughts are good for you.
Now those thoughts,
insightful specifically,
we'll make you,
we'll,
we'll lead you to make choices.
Okay.
Now the,
the whole conversation around ThreeWill is actually quite interesting and
definitely one of the reasons that we sometimes debate freewill is the whole
idea of space time that all of space and all of time has already exists right
now.
The interesting side of,
of freewill.
And believe it or not,
it's actually one of the ideas of what I'm writing next.
I have a three ideas I'm working on.
One of them is,
uh,
is,
is what I call an understanding fate.
And,
and the concept of freewill basically is that you did make a choice on which,
which tee shirt you,
you chose to wear today you had a choice of blue or black and you make a choice
of blue.
And I call those micro choices.
Okay.
And I then I tend to believe that your fate,
that the,
the,
the destination of your final fate is going to be,
uh,
the sum of three free is one of them is your micro choice.
That's your own freewill plus the freewill of all of the other beings.
Because you know what,
maybe the laundry guy did not bring back the,
uh,
you know,
the black tee shirts.
So you really did not have that choice at all.
And then the third would be,
uh,
the free will of the universe.
If we tend to believe that the universe is following certain equations and
functions,
maybe,
you know,
there could be an earthquake in the morning that leads you to rush and take her
one tee shirt other than instead of the other.
So do we have freewill?
I tend to believe we have the will to make our micro choices.
Okay.
As a matter of fact,
I tend to believe that we have the will to impact on the universe is choices and
definitely on the choices of others.
Okay.
Uh,
and much more importantly in my view,
I believe that we have the will to impact on our thoughts.
And that truly is the core of salt for happy that we have the choice.
I mean,
I you,
you chose to sit in this room and focus on my words for the last 45 minutes,
right?
Uh,
we,
we can control what our brain does.
You can tell your brain to do something and it will do it.
As a matter of fact,
you've never told your brain to do something.
And it said,
hey,
you know what?
I'm really not interested to raise my right arm now.
So No,
no brain series new,
we want the right arm.
And No,
you know,
um,
it,
it raises the right arm.
You'll tell it,
raise the right arm it goes to,
so I'll do what you tell me.
Yet,
when suffering starts to happen,
when the incessant thoughts starts to happen,
somehow we let the brain be the boss.
Somehow we tell it,
hey,
you know what?
Yes,
you can take me to misery.
I will just follow,
right?
As I told you,
you know,
I,
I could have had the choice of letting my brain telling,
telling me things like,
you drove alley there,
you chose the wrong hospital,
you,
you know,
did this or you did that.
Or I could tell my brain,
you know,
what brain,
let's move this to use for thinking and try to do the best out of the situation
we have.
Maybe if we can get 10 million people to be happy,
it will smile upon you.
Right.
So it's a choice and that's in my view,
the biggest part of your freewill.
What about when you're thinking in a dream state?
Yeah.
I'm not qualified to answer dreams yet.
Again,
surprisingly.
You guys are catchy touching on interesting topics that I'm researching at the
moment.
I'm uh,
I don't know.
I th I think that,
um,
the dreams are a very interesting indication of something I call the illusion of
self.
That we do exist in forms that go beyond the physical form.
Uh,
exactly how that salt happens.
I haven't dedicated enough research for this.
Okay.
Can I,
can I just,
before you ask the next question,
however,
understand this.
Sometimes when a,
when a bad dream happens,
we go like,
okay,
events missed my expectations and we feel bad.
Surprisingly,
even though there were no events.
Okay.
So it was just a dream,
right?
Thanks for talking.
As you know,
Google,
we're now going through purpose season and if I write in my perf results,
well knowledge is an illusion.
Control's an illusion.
I don't actually know or did anything.
And if I'm,
I go into the kind of how can I improve next quarter or next cycle?
And I go,
time is an illusion.
It's a,
it's not predictable.
It seems very kind of contradictory to a successful career at Google.
So how do you reconcile these two seemingly contradictory viewpoints?
So,
so I,
I should start by saying I've had a very good career,
so it seems that this,
this stuff works,
right?
Uh,
but let's put it this way.
Um,
there is nothing better to be successful than to acknowledge the truth.
You understand that?
So,
so the best of us out of those will make decisions based on truly what's going
on,
not what we think is going on.
Now let me tell you this,
in my career,
I will,
I will say that one of the biggest,
biggest things that completely propelled me forward was that complete conviction
that I know nothing at all.
Okay.
That you guys know so much more than I do.
And so I would sit in meeting rooms and say,
Hey,
this is my point of view.
But because I sit on the top of the table,
it does not mean I know more than,
than,
you know,
as a matter of fact,
most of the time,
you know much more than I do,
most of the time you are so close to the reality that you know much more than I
do.
And that openness to,
I don't know,
someone else might know or the collective wisdom of all of us.
You remember the wisdom of the crowd was something that we built Google on top
of them,
uh,
on top of so,
so,
so the idea of we can get closer to the truth if we actually assume that we
don't exactly know is not a bad thing to do in,
uh,
in Perth.
And often when you look at your own skill set and say to yourself,
hey,
by the way,
I don't know this,
it gives you a target to improve.
It gives you something to start to learn and try to know.
That's one.
Control is an illusion is actually the story of my life.
Like I'm a businessman.
How often does people who you know,
may have been in my teams in the past,
what's come to me and say,
hey mo,
by the way,
this deed is going wrong.
This is not going the way we want it to be.
We expected it to close this way.
It's going to close that way.
Right?
And you could take this and panic or you could take this and simply say like,
you know Tom Hanks in in a,
in Apollo 13 you'd say,
Houston,
we have a problem,
right?
It's okay to have a problem.
We really don't have much control so let's respond to it.
Let's work on it.
And you know,
normally actually people who worked in my teams or remember that,
I would always say your target in the absence of force majeure in the absence of
something that completely goes out of control is this right time.
There is,
there are two types of time.
That is what I call it,
practical time.
I discussed that at length in the book there is practical time and there is
brain time.
Practical time is when I say to myself I need to be in Palo Alto by four 30
right?
It's Friday.
So the traffic is going to be a little early.
So you know it's going to take me 40 minutes instead of 25 minutes and I need
five minutes to park and two minutes to walk.
So I need to plan 47 minutes.
Let me plan 15 minutes.
There is no emotion in this.
It's practical time.
I,
I look at the world as it is.
I design my time patterns and I deploy them and I execute,
right?
There is no emotions involved.
Brain time is the stress happening.
If I'm actually going to Palo Alto and I leave 15 minutes early and there is an
accident on the road and I sit there and I start to curse myself and of course
my life and tell him I said myself,
oh my God,
they're never going to meet me again.
They're never going to talk to me as a again.
As a matter of fact,
they're probably going to tell the government and I'm never going to be allowed
in America again,
right?
We will all,
we all allow ourselves to go through that thinking,
but how much of it is true?
Right?
And it's all related to that stress.
The time puts on top of you.
Okay.
If you manage to move the stress of time from your thinking back to the past
and,
and regret thinking forward to the future and feel warm,
feeling worried,
you know,
that incessant side of your brain to the insightful side of your head.
Make time a practical practice that you work on.
You won't be unhappy and you will perform a lot better.
How often do you get this?
100% right.
Okay.
Uh,
never.
Oh yeah,
I mean cds to Yo,
what'd you up?
I'm not his holiness the Dalai Lama by the way.
Okay.
Uh,
no,
I I,
you know,
as I,
as I started,
I uh,
as I started my presentation,
I,
I fight in meetings.
I get stuck on the one on one,
like everyone and occasionally I will find a,
uh,
you know,
my self feeling unhappy.
I all I know is that um,
it's almost like software,
right?
You,
you have an operating system that's running this brain and there is a few lines
of code that every time you will run your brain will do something different than
what's suppose to what it's,
what it normally does.
If,
if let loose.
Okay.
So,
uh,
so the first few times,
you know,
I discovered my model,
it was very hard to apply and the more I practiced,
the more I told myself this is an illusion.
That is an illusion.
It became a little more second nature.
Okay.
Is it all the time?
I hope to get there someday,
you know,
that would be the Olympian championship of happiness,
but oh no,
I don't think anyone is there.
Okay.
I wanted to ask you a question about consciousness and um,
and how we've apart a large part of what you spoke was sort of,
um,
distilling down emotions and sort of having a objective control over it so that
you have,
you can actually solve for happy.
Um,
the other sets of emotions around expanded consciousness would be around say
gratitude or,
um,
where being human and being emotional about those things is a different
experience all together.
I would love to hear some of your thoughts around those aspects of
consciousness.
So again,
two,
two parts to the question.
I like to start by talking about emotions
because sometimes I,
you know,
I may come across as if I'm distancing myself from emotions.
As a matter of fact,
I'm not at all.
Uh,
I,
I embrace my emotions fully.
you know,
I feed them and experience them.
Uh,
as much as I can harsh by the way or happy.
there is an interesting approach to going through life.
I,
I normally have the analogy of life and video games.
Uh,
and you know,
it,
unless you experience all of life,
uh,
or it's tough times and good times,
it would be a very,
very,
very boring video game.
Uh,
he,
the,
imagine if you started to play Halo and all you had to do is push the forward
button and just go through it until the end of the level.
Where's the fun in debt?
Right?
So emotions are to be embraced but,
but emotions when they become overwhelming,
by the way,
either way,
you need to start to become aware where is the emotion coming from?
Because every emotion,
by the way,
and we do this exercise in the training.
Every emotion stems from a thought,
not an event.
It stems from a thought.
So the taxi driver is rude,
is the event.
The thought might be something like people should not be rude to me.
I should be respected.
This is threatening to my kids and their future.
Okay.
Whatever that thought is,
is what drives that,
you know,
a feeling of anger or anxiety or worry or whatever that is that comes as a
result of the route driver.
So,
so we need to be aware of those.
We need to embrace those.
And then when we start to realize that they're taking over and all of a,
an overwhelming us,
we need to start tracing them and finding out why are they doing that,
which starts the stem from,
are those thoughts through at all?
Now consciousness goes way beyond that.
Okay.
And consciousness.
I,
I always like to use the example of love because I think love is very,
is a very universal and very understudied a concept.
So I call it my,
uh,
my romantic,
unscientific chapter if you want.
And,
and there is,
there are two types of love,
but there is that,
uh,
that love that happens in your brain.
I love you because let's say I love Google because of the cafes.
If Larry Decides to cancel the cafe's tomorrow,
I no longer love Google.
There is a reason for my love,
but I love butterflies.
That's it.
There is no,
because I have no idea why.
I just love butterflies,
right when whichever shape,
whichever,
if it's Pale Gray,
I love butterflies,
right?
I don't know,
I admire their story.
I don't know.
Right?
There is that kind of love and that kind of love truly is awareness extreme.
That's you connecting with the rest of being okay there.
You know,
I,
I feel as love for me,
even though AI is thousands of miles away,
I am my daughter in Montreal right now.
Those kinds of awarenesses if you want,
are truly the top of all awareness.
This is truly when you start to connect with the review,
okay?
The one that's not rushing through life everyday trying to get the next iPhone.
The real you is the one that's aware beyond this.
Okay.
And it's rare and it takes a ton of practice.
And I think the problem is that we dismiss it because it doesn't seem very
scientific.
But you asked about dreams.
Okay.
You ask about all of those.
UN understood,
you know,
miss not an not understood an unexplained events in our life where we go beyond
the physical where we can,
you know,
whether you feel that someone needs you to call them or whatever.
Okay.
And all of these awarenesses are probably the next stage.
I,
I'd,
I'd encourage everyone who's a modern day warrior to start by the awarenesses of
this.
Okay.
To feel the pain in your neck,
to feel the,
you know,
the coordinates in the room to feel the,
the time passing by to fill the thoughts popping up in your head to feel the
link between the thought and that emotion.
Okay.
To become aware of all of these.
And then as you progress in your belts,
if you want,
you get to the black belt of all awareness,
which is consciousness.
The topic is a Mello from the individual level.
But are you,
I know have a,
you know,
there's a background or from other culture and also have a emerging market of,
from a society point of view,
we talk about these,
uh,
you know,
happiness a globally,
if from coucher farms is a global,
from a societal level,
you think what kind of main challenge and we can contribute it,
you know,
to live to the happiness.
It definitely is not a secret that happiness is becoming more and more of a
challenge across all cultures,
but,
but it's also not a secret that there are cultures that are happier than others.
Right.
And I wouldn't want to classify cultures by east or west or by,
you know,
Asian or European or whatever.
I'd probably try to pinpoint the industrial revolution.
I would say that between the industrial revolution and World War II where points
before which,
uh,
you know,
we were a lot more in touch with the reality of being a human.
Okay.
I think,
I think what happened in the industrial revolution is that we started to focus a
lot more on progress and productivity than our own wellbeing and happiness.
Okay.
And why do we realize that by the way,
uh,
those who are happy are 12% more productive.
This is scientific then than those who are not,
uh,
at the aggregate level.
Uh,
you know,
a big company might not care much if you're slightly less productive than you
should be because you're unhappy.
Okay.
Now,
um,
the,
the whole approach to chasing more,
the whole approach to being pressured by time,
the whole approach to be more individual focused on your own success is,
uh,
it is a spiral,
right?
Because,
because,
you know,
you start in a culture where the society is taking care of each other and then
you end up in a society where if you fail,
you're going to be homeless.
Okay.
And then the importance of you not going through that threat of being homeless
becomes even more important,
right?
And so you strive harder and harder and you fall further and further away from
your happiness.
There is a core to this operating system to this machine.
And the core of this machine is our needs are much less than we think they are.
And our,
uh,
our universal,
um,
indicator of wellbeing if you want,
is to feel happy.
You know,
if it's,
it's almost again,
part of your survival function.
If you're happy,
that's sort of a signal for your brain that everything's okay,
right?
But it's not a reason to slack,
We need to worry.
We need to,
you know,
that that's your brain thinking.
We need to worry.
We need to ensure your survival.
And now in the modern world,
survivor goes much,
much beyond running away from the tiger.
Okay?
It goes into your four zero one K it goes into your,
you know,
uh,
the kind of car that you drive it,
it goes into,
you know,
do I have the ability to get the latest phone or not?
Okay.
And none of that,
none of that.
I promise you,
none of that will ever make you happy.
Happy is not to be found outside.
Your Ip is there inside your,
it's your default state.
It's how we are all born.
How old children,
you know,
join our world.
And if they're fed,
if they're safe,
if they're loved,
they're happy,
they don't need the toy to be happy.
They can play with their toes and be happy.
You understand?
And now,
and now,
by adding all of the pressures of the industrial revolution,
I think what we ended and the fears that we got after the world war and,
and the Great Depression,
we started to aim for that insurance policy.
I just want to make sure I'm safe.
And if I pay that for my,
with my happiness,
that's okay.
At least I know I'm safe.
You know what?
Most of us are already safe.
I mean,
you know,
I,
if anyone is watching this video anywhere in the world,
they have a screen that they can look at.
That's probably the luckiest 1% in the world,
right?
Um,
and we still don't see it that way.
We continue to strive and strive and strive.
The cultures that are happier,
our cultures that prioritize the present moment,
they prioritize their happiness,
they prioritize time with the ones they love.
Okay.
And they understand that life will go on with its harshness.
I know that with it's good times and if they can do something about the
harshness,
they'll fix it.
If they cannot,
they'll accept,
well,
I called committed acceptance and try again.
Okay.
These are the happiest cultures in the world.
Um,
so as I understand it,
you've been on sabbatical working on this book and congratulations on launching
it.
Curious to hear what the next steps are,
what else you're working on.
You touched on three additional research projects and also how Googlers can help
propel those missions forward.
I'm,
I think I've never been more in the state of flow as I am right now.
So,
so I'm truly moving with the events of life as they happen,
trying really hard to maximize the impact of salt for happy,
but also really,
really,
really struggling with so many ideas that I'm taking notes about.
And hopefully you will sit down and write soon.
Bye.
Also made a promise to come back and hopefully do the best I can to continue the
incredible mission of Google.
Right?
Uh,
between all of these,
all I know is that,
is this,
I have a mission of 10,
making 10 million people happy.
If I make one person happy,
I'm very happy.
Okay.
If I make two,
I'm a little happier.
If I make a hundred,
then I'm even happier and I don't know how far this will go.
Okay.
I'm hoping to be able to get a happy people that grasp the concepts to be the
ambassadors of the concept.
Uh,
I'm also hoping to find a technology,
technological ways,
maybe apps or online,
you know,
presence or whatever that allows us to spread the message even further.
And I'm hoping that Googlers,
and many of you,
I know many of who attended the training have been truly ambassadors of this.
You know,
uh,
I've,
I've spoken to,
it's spoken at Stanford and many other places as a result of people spreading
the words and saying this,
this changed my life.
Right?
So,
um,
all I know for now is that for the next three and a half months or most,
uh,
I'm completely dedicated to this,
trying to,
to list down my notes on the next few thoughts if I have the time and uh,
that by July I'm back and I'm trying to put 14 hours a day instead of eight so
that I can continue to do both as best as I can.
All right.
I think we're going to need to wrap it up now.
Thank you so much for being here.
For last words.
Can you let people know where they can get the book and if they were touched by
this message where they can mark that they were
oh yeah.
Yeah.
So,
so the,
the f forget happiness,
the businessmen now.
Okay.
I have a counter on my website.
If you go to solve for happy.com and if I managed to,
could send you a message that made you a little bit happier,
click on the counter.
It says you made me happy.
Thank you.
And,
uh,
and I,
I,
uh,
of course,
you know,
the book is launching our in on the 21st of March,
so you can get it on Google play books or,
or on Amazon and uh,
yeah,
uh,
I promise you it will make a difference.
So,
uh,
so I hope,
I hope you can find your happiness in this.
I'm more@soulforhappy.com I give a one day service level agreement.
If your email is shorter than four lines,
and yes,
I do,
I do ask you to get in touch and give me ideas and tell me how I can make this
better.
Uh,
at the same time,
if you are,
you know,
reading and finding thoughts that you would like to discuss,
there is nothing that is more enjoyable for me then learning new perspectives
and new points of view.
So,
yeah,
do stay in touch and I hope to,
uh,
to make you a little happier.
Thank you so much.
[inaudible].